[Music]
you wrote a this documentary a
documentary on HAP unhappiness and and
and how people did like my work where
you're trying to find what is it that
makes people happy did you learn
anything useful that we could we could
impart the audit you know that the thing
that I you know there was all these
studies back in the early seventies just
simply smiling even if you felt like
didn't feel like smiling at all just
smiling does all these things to your
body and shortly after that these these
laughter clubs where people would
literally laugh for no particular reason
they started to spring up and these were
studied where they would find that the
the levels of epinephrine which is sort
of makes your blood vessels constrict
and cortisol which is a stress hormone
those would go down simply if you just
tried laughing for no particular reason
you're saying that it does you don't
have to even see something funny or
experience something funny laugh
artificially make yourself laugh and
that's healthy for you absolutely if you
if you would if you just people would
line up in these circles and and and
laugh and they would have all these
benefits to their body their immune
system would improve those stress
hormones again would go down you want to
try it yeah yeah yeah sure should we do
this
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Darien catches - come on will
does that work what he's doing right
there I'm not sure about that okay but
you know just really there is a study
that lady's sunglasses increase in
epinephrine in the body yeah so I saw
just for your ginger like and then other
people start to laugh as well in
response to it so it becomes quite
infectious yeah it's just an amazing
thing again in the early 70s people
started studying this and people would
talk about you know all sorts of
different disease processes in the body
sort of improving he's smiling
is that good is that good just smiling
well yeah that's it that's a creepy
smile that's not a good smell I can't
teach him to smile when I ask you about
something it's a little controversial in
the rest of the country everyone here in
California seems to be fine with it I'm
talking about medical marijuana
dispensaries now settle down gang all
right
Shaggy and Scooby are in the my uh
here's the question I know people I know
people that work for me
no not naming any names people that are
on this stage right now
no I know people who tell me oh yeah I
just went and I told the doctor I you
know I have like a slight tickle in the
back of my throat I have a little bit of
anxiety no questions asked they get
medical marijuana how do you feel about
this well you know I mean obviously
anything can be abused
yeah and that's sort of that's sort of
the issue with the medical marijuana I
think there's some pretty legitimate
medical uses for marijuana I mean people
have talked about for chronic illness
for people who are nausea 'td people
stimulate appetite you can have bad
vibes there you go so there in life is
whose mellow has been harsh sure let me
write you a prescription for uncoolest
but I think you know it's it's something
you know you haven't won 16 states now I
think in the Columbia so I think there's
some legitimate uses but I'm not exactly
sure where it goes from here there's
crazy here in California that I see
that's always it yeah it's part of the
happy meal I got on board you Tom Andy
yeah literally my kids are like what's
this